i did like mushrooms yesterday so i
don't feel like i didn't have a real you
did mushrooms yeah did you really yeah
how was it i'm kind of tired i couldn't
imagine like just taking two days off
and then going right back into that yeah
it's gotta fry your brain pretty hard no
i mean i mean it's like
i think the effect on your brain is like
less than alcohol or oh is it other
drugs yeah i mean cool i'm gonna do it
every night
oh i mean like not if you do it like
every single day no i'm joking yeah
but i just mean like going out and doing
it for one night yeah
but you're just tired right you're not
like hungover no no yeah my brain
definitely feels tired though
i do have fun
yeah for sure he's
i was just laughing at everything yeah
everything was funny
and then
i hit the real like
mushroom phase
when i would
all right this is the worst
image but basically i sat down to take a
[ __ ] and i'm on my phone
but
i started getting this crazy depth
perception where
my phone felt like really massive and
then i'd look out like from my phone and
it felt like i was looking down very far
at my feet it was the weirdest sensation
and then
when sunset happened i was just outside
just like peeking like yo
these [ __ ] colors man
this [ __ ] is crazy
he's looking like an idiot yo y'all
gotta look at the sky and [ __ ] the grass
is breathing yeah yeah yeah i had i i
got a little bit of that i was looking
at some trees and they're kind of
they're doing that
yeah i'm like oh it's like mid-summer
yeah
yeah it was cool i want to do it again
and actually get the trip yeah
other people got the trip
and
we have a lot of wood in our house
and
it was just freaking him out like yo
there's like eyes all over the floor
yeah and then do your dressers like
looking at me
oh my god this reminds me i was i was at
the um
i was at this restaurant in malibu and
these two guys walk in they walk up to
this table like in front of us yeah and
immediately they like they're like oh
this table is perfect
it's like they're freaking out over the
table and i'm like what the [ __ ] is this
like it's a table it's an open table
wasn't that busy yeah and they're like
dude this table is perfect
oh good like
great great call on the table yeah i'm
like what is it with this table yeah and
they sit down
and immediately they stand back up they
take off their shirts and they go like
out the side gate down to the ocean a
little weird like they're the only ones
no one else is like on the beach or like
yeah it's not like a beach day yeah and
they go on the water and they come back
out and again i see them walk up and go
[ __ ] that was so sick
dap each other up i'm like all he did is
was like wade in the ocean for a second
and they come back and they sit down on
the table and
and i didn't even realize at this point
but it became very clear they were
tripping when the one guy starts like
looking at the cutlery
and he zones in on the color and he's
like
he starts freaking out like dude
this is [ __ ] crazy man i don't know
what's happening with it and i'm like
watching like my convert like my table
is having a conversation i'm zoned out
because i'm just watching this guy freak
out over a fork and knife and he said
come over here dude come over here come
over here and the other guy comes over
and they both just are like looking at
this cutlery just like
i can't believe
do you see that
it's like it's it's it was so [ __ ]
funny dude
yeah man shrooms is a
it man
it made me like act
like i was 16. i kept pretending that i
was
spiraling on the shrooms so i just
periodically like i in the middle of a
conversation i pretend to like run and
jump off like my balcony
but i just kept
like i talked to someone like yeah and
then i just stop and stare and be like
guys
it's taking me over
[Laughter]
it's crawling all over me
the nightmare the nightmare they're
doing that nightmare nightmare
the silver people kept joking about like
gaslighting everyone on shrooms and like
yo you see that it's like it's not there
it's not there
there's this drone that kept flying
around my neighborhood
and everyone kept saying there's no
drone
and i walked out to go to the backyard
from inside our house and i see the
drone flying
i just
run down the stairs eyes biggest helmet
[Laughter]
is not lying it's the government they're
following us no it was it was good i'd
i'll definitely do it again but need
some time off
yeah
the
fatigue is is real yeah i took a woman's
multivitamin last night before i went to
sleep why i just you know
i've i was told that multivitamin can
help and we only had women's
multivitamins so
yeah
i had to prove women they know what
they're doing yeah i'm taking one of
their vitamins yeah what's up yeah
yeah women vitamins like definitely take
care of you better yeah yeah yeah you
know chicks like they're always like
taking care of their body and [ __ ] yeah
does your [ __ ] feel better today yeah
it feels great
yeah
yeah that was actually the craziest part
of shrooms is when my penis went inside
my body
and turned into a vagina
i see if you do enough of that [ __ ]
you do enough of that [ __ ]
i i see how it turns you into a
like a psycho where you're like yo
everything's connected
like i'm in this wood right now and the
wood is looking back at me and like
we're all just you know
so i that i think is a cautionary tale
about shrooms because if they feel good
at least i felt good yeah
i
and i like that um
it's kind of like weed but you're not
i would describe it like you don't get
the tired aspect yeah and how it hits
you in waves makes it fun yeah you're
like what the [ __ ] is this gonna be
yeah and then we just kept joking about
me like smashing my face with a rock
[Laughter]
yeah just friendly yeah just friendly
happy trip stuff just shrooms things
yeah
that's so funny you should you should
mutilate your own face yeah with that
rock yo what if you just [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah it's uh it was cool the weirdest
part was i ate a banana
and are you not supposed to eat during
shrooms
um
no i don't think so i think you're fine
i think mostly they just say it makes
your stomach like if you eat them just
the shrooms it's like [ __ ] up your
stomach because they're like gross
right
yeah no because i
i ate a banana and i don't know if the
sugar like
in the i don't know that was the
weirdest i felt i ate a banana then my
whole body felt like jelly
and
everyone was talking i had to sit down
and they're asking me well
you okay
i ate a banana i don't feel too good
they're like you ate a banana on shrooms
yeah
that's the number one thing you're not
supposed to do yeah literally what yeah
what what noel you're turning yellow oh
god yeah
well i can throw it up it's too late man
wait a minute it's taking hold
you're
[Music]
it's so funny what's up with noel he
thinks he's a banana